Do you know anyone around you who has had cosmetic plastic surgery?
I met one of my ex - colleagues the other day,...
...and I couldn't recognize her at first because she had a totally different look.
Tell you what, almost two-thirds of the people I personally know,...
...that's including both men and women, have had plastic surgery.
I'm telling you, two-thirds!
They are not even like models or anything like that...
...they're just ordinary people with normal jobs.
I was actually shocked.
Now, would you have plastic surgery if you had like a free coupon for surgery?
What would you want to fix?
What do you think of undergoing such surgery?
If I had to pick one surgery for myself, I would choose a nose job.
Well, lots of images come to my mind when I think of plastic surgery.
Recent polls say about 58% of teenagers want to have plastic surgery in Korea.
A large number of my friends have had at least one part fixed.
I think plastic surgery is becoming more common,...
...especially in Korea where people do usually pay attention to their appearance.
People, in Korea, commonly think that getting plastic, or cosmetic surgery,...
...makes them feel more confident.
This could be important for situations like a job interview.
So, I'm not totally against it,...
...but what's more important is what you have inside of yourself.
You hear this quite often: "True beauty, is inner beauty."